The joe rogan experience.
If I was a young man,
I've got an argument.
Someone,
I would relive that argument like every
day for like 10 minutes for like a year.
Maybe I'll come back to it a year later.
Yes.
Fucking God.
I should have told that.
Fuck Shit.
Oh fuck you mister.
You have to like go through your notes.
Like what was I going to say to him?
Oh yeah,
I was going to say that I used
to talk about this on stage.
This is totally true.
When I was a,
I guess I was like 26,
I live,
I was living in Encino and I rented this
house and it had an orange tree in the
front yard and I didn't pay my bills.
It's very irresponsible.
So this guy came over,
uh,
I had turned the power back on and the
guy came over to turn the power on and it
seemed like a nice guy.
I said,
hey man,
uh,
those oranges a delicious,
if you want me to go grab one.
And he goes,
okay,
thanks.
So the guy took nine fucking oranges
and I sat there watching them like this
motherfucker,
it's taken more orange.
I can't believe this shit.
And to this day,
man,
I have to fight off urge.
No,
no,
no.
Not that story.
Three times a day it's real.
Like I was an asshole.
To this day I'll be in my car and I'm
driving down the street and I'll just go
nine fucking oranges do.
Really?
That was 1993
did I tell you the story that the loan
told me that I tell it on this podcast?
No.
Shit like this never happens.
Me and pivot one time flew to,
we're going to fight to a Mayweather
fight and we get on the plane and fucking
Stallone is waiting.
[inaudible]
come on.
I guess we're going to
a fight with Stallone.
It's great thing about Stallone.
He knows what his good stories,
ours.
He,
you know what I mean?
He like knows what people
want to hear about.
They want to hear about rocky.
They wanna hear about fucking,
they want to hear what,
so he's talking about he was
directing the movie staying alive.
Oh,
uh,
yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah,
he was,
and it was a Travolta movie that,
that Frank Stallone
sang on the soundtrack.
That is correct.
Um,
so yes.
So Stallone said that he,
he goes,
so I,
I called John Up to the
house for a meeting,
but then get that song,
play that song while the is going on.
He goes,
frank Stallone,
this is the end,
I think it's called.
This is the end,
and staying alive.
He goes,
he goes,
so John came up and he goes,
John's got a real food issue.
People don't know that.
And he goes,
he goes,
John comes up,
we're sitting at a table and he goes,
now,
my wife had made some
homemade fudge that day.
So we sit at the table,
my wife puts out some fudge Travolta
proceeds to eat the entire plate of fun.
Oh yeah,
this fucking guy obey.
He goes,
which first of all,
his fucking route,
which is fucking made
me laugh my head off.
And that was like that.
He hasn't forgotten that he,
that's his orange story.
Does it,
was that,
is that dangerous when you have a
situation like that and you know,
your guy is going to face him?
Is that,
is it dangerous?
Is in any,
like to have
that attitude to go into a Dick
Glover doesn't have that attitude.
Right?
He doesn't,
I mean,
as much as he likes him,
he's there to do the job
was a glove,
was there,
did Java and clover.
It didn't have the closeness
that we did to him cause he came,
uh,
Kyle came around more when a
Glover was on his hiatus to Brazil.
So he didn't have quite the closest.
He really liked him.
But I mean the,
the MMA spirit,
um,
and I'll take out an m the maa spirit,
martial arts,
um,
is just so different than boxing,
which is,
I mean,
technically a martial art too,
but they just don't carry themselves.
Most of them,
like martial artists,
they carry themselves like
more like thugs or just,
they don't have the same comradery.
I mean,
I have a picture of us,
Siler,
of his fight in,
um,
in Kentucky.
I didn't even know,
I forgot the guy's name.
Really tough strong wrestler.
Um,
he lost a close decision.
It was his last fight.
Um,
but they were actually the day
before the fight at the Wayne.
Um,
they were,
they were hanging out
playing video games together,
like huddle together.
And I was,
and I didn't know who
that guy was at first.
And I walked over,
hey,
what's up man?
What's your name?
And he's like,
so and so I go,
aren't you guys fighting tomorrow?
And they go,
yeah,
coach,
we just gotta hold up.
We got to finish this game.
And they hung out for like
two hours at the way in.
And then the day of the fight,
they were like hanging out in the dressing
room and then they went out and put
on a brutal,
I mean,
it was a very brutal fight.
It was a good fight and it was a brutal,
they didn't hold back anything.
They definitely fought.
Yeah.
It was Dennis Bermudez,
who's a great guy as well.
Yeah,
he's,
and I mean,
and that's the comradery.
You don't see that in boxing and MMA.
You see it more than you don't?
What do you think about bitcoin?
What
do you think about crypto currencies?
What do you think about emerging?
Look,
there are a lot of people,
um,
that are libertarian or some
people that believe in hard money.
There are people that
believe in gold that,
that are in bitcoin.
And you know,
I think that,
you know,
a lot of people who,
bought bitcoin a few
years ago and you know,
I didn't buy it and sure.
You know,
I wish I had bought them because
I would be selling them now.
In fact,
I would have already sold them,
so I dumped it already.
Oh yeah.
Why is that?
Because I think it's,
I think it's a bubble.
I think that,
I think that between the here with Vegas
casinos to casinos just start accepting
bitcoins.
Yeah.
But you know,
I think merchants starting to accept
bitcoins are actually going to be negative
for Bitcoin's not positive.
Why is that?
Well,
here's why.
You know,
when bitcoins went up from
Penny's a coin to $1,000,
right.
Do you know you,
you really couldn't do much with them
except whoredom so close before you go
there,
I'm sorry,
sorry to interrupt you,
but explain to me what
is it actually worth?
What is a bitcoin is worth whatever
somebody will give you for it.
I mean it has no actual value because
you can't do anything with it.
Okay.
All you can do is give
it to somebody else.
So is it in ones,
it means it in one bitcoin to bitcoins.
Is the volume.
What is the,
uh,
they usually sell them in one bitcoin,
but you can pay,
you can break a bitcoin up into
like a hundred thousand peaks of it.
Give me how much is a pizza?
How many bitcoins is a pizza?
Well,
a fraction because right now and in fire,
well an entire bitcoin right now is what?
$950.
So how many pizzas you can get?
A pizza is like $9 50 cents and
you get laid a hundred pizza.
They don't have any other
thing other than a bitcoin.
That's it.
It's just a bitcoin.
Well,
I mean,
you can get bitcoin.
I mean you can get,
you know,
fractional coins.
You don't have to buy a whole coin.
Yeah,
but they need to figure it out.
You have to have like Nicole quarter.
No,
it's just bitcoin.
You get dollar $10 a deck,
a deck.
A coin is sent a coin.
I don't know what it's the
exact opposite of pesos,
like a million pesos.
But the important thing is that
you can't do anything with it.
You know,
there's no actual value with
you can buy drugs right now.
Right?
Well silkroad yes,
but you,
you can spend it as long as
somebody is willing to take it.
Right.
But there's no end user.
There's no,
it's not a commodity.
The same with our currency.
Currently our currency is crap.
I mean,
I'm not,
you know why bitcoin is
crap in our currency is the
difference between the crap,
the government issues and bitcoins is
the crap the government issues for now as
legal tender.
I can,
you know,
people will accept it.
I can pay my taxes in it.
I mean,
I have a use for it.
Right.
But it's the government's.
It's saying it's legal tender isn't the
government enforcing being someone who's
so antigovernment as you,
I would assume that that's why own gold,
but you would enjoy something
like bitcoin coming along,
but it has no real value.
I recognize that it could collapse.
I don't,
there's no a value.
Isn't there a value?
Just like we do tomorrow?
Everybody can agree there's no value.
See,
gold was valuable long
before it became money.
Bitcoin had no value
until it became money,
but I don't think it can
withstand the test of time.
Okay.